covid now kovit it's funny because some
of the uh enlightened liberals or
whatever you want to call them they've
in the last few weeks or maybe two
months or so they've sort of come out
against some of the mandates and the
draconian policies and things and i
think what you'll find here
uh is that uh bill maher and joe rogan
are going to make some sense on this
kind of thing
i probably have but it's like i don't
know
i would trust it it came from the cdc if
they if they personally admitted yes
this is or the people who make the
vaccine
um anybody else i don't know but then
again they could be lying i also don't
tell them don't trust them to tell me
the truth about whether they did put it
in there
and i don't know what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
is that i don't make
so don't tell me things like just do
what we say don't question it
when have we ever been wrong
a lot all the time i've been wrong a lot
and you just don't know a lot so just
don't tell me well we are perfectly
certain that this vaccine is safe or we
are perfectly certain that these x-rays
are a low dose and they won't you don't
[ __ ] know that you don't know what
all these different things these there's
like 50 000 chemicals we have in our
body that we didn't have 100 years ago
you don't know what the interchange of
all these elements is doing to me and me
personally it might be different than
you
so just don't have that attitude of just
get it in you
yes we are the people who know
not just that but they're making insane
amounts of profit from that where yes
we're supposed to pretend
that they've been honest
about the risks of things in the past
okay i think rogan really hits the key
part there right these people who are
making an awful lot of money and stand
to make a future awful lot of money and
who have uh put in legal language so
they'll never
be held to account if anything's wrong
with any of these vaccines or anything
else like perhaps that's what this is
really about but but mar is basically
making sense although the first thing he
says there i would trust the cdc or the
people who make the vaccines and then he
kind of realizes what he said there and
he goes but they could be lying so why
should we trust them i mean two years
after this whole thing do you really
trust the cdc do you really trust the
vaccine makers i'm not saying they're
all liars i'm not saying that they're
all evil and i have no doubt that there
are good employees who work there and i
ha and i have no but we know that
they've even fudged the numbers even
over the last couple weeks they fudged
the numbers related to deaths and
infections and a whole bunch other stuff
remember there was one thing what was
the line that they used about the
numbers that they screwed up related to
covid deaths they it was an accounting
error or something they forgot to carry
the one in one of those things or it was
what they called a clerical error
it was a database error something like
that um so mark sort of says the right
thing at first he was like well uh
well
the the cdc i would trust them but then
he realizes oh no why should i just
trust them but the problem is liberals
put too much faith in big institutions
above them i think probably because
they're trying to find other gods
because usually they don't believe in
gods but something about believing in
systems and believing in something is
very important to the human experience
so you can run around saying you're an
atheist but then go oh but the cdc said
something i have to believe it but then
he also has a logical brain and a
logical brain goes wait just because
they said it probably not true possibly
not true hey i'm still back here
okay fine but he sort of got it but once
again it's like okay you're getting it
two years later because when there was a
cost to getting it over the last two
years when many of us were screaming
that there should be no mandates that
you should not be forcing children to
wear masks that it should be up to the
individuals and all the things where
were you bill maher and again this is
not an attack on bill maher this is this
is a genuine this is a genuine hand out
of like let's let's do this let's get to
the end let's start building the new
world you should be part of the new
world obviously but when there was a
cost to having any of the opinions that
you now have you didn't have those
opinions you were not going after fauci
you were not
was he loudly screaming i mean please
someone find me a video where he was
ranting and raving against mandates i'll
gladly show that video tomorrow and i'll
apologize but when a whole bunch of us
were where were you now it's very easy
to say it right it's the easiest
possible thing
to say
but you believe in the cdc that's what
you're saying you believe in the in
these big institutions